Welcome to problem set three, let's dive right in.
In the unit, we talked about a problem called k-coloring,
and just in case you don't remember it, let's go over real quick.
Let's say we had a graph and let's say we want to give all the vertices different colors.
Well, not different colors,
but we want to give them colors so that neighboring vertices never have the same color
like keyword on a map for instance.
Let's go ahead and start, I would green color this one.
That means if we want to move to another color, we can color the adjacent ones a different color
but we can't color any of these green because this is connected to all the vertices.
So, let's start off this one and color that red but that means we can't color that red.
We can color one of these red, so let's go ahead and do that too.
Let's color this one red. That means this one can no longer be colored red either.
Neither of this can be colored red or green, so let's color them purple.
And now, we completely colored this graph with three colors,
and at least for k>2, whether a graph can be colored and k many colors,
is an NP complete problem.
Now, in order to show the k-coloring is complete,
really what we can do is simply reduce clique to k-coloring,
and there are two basic facts that help us to do this.
The first question we need to answer is that if a graph contains a clique of size k,
then how many colors are needed to color the graph at minimum?
And the second question is, conversely if a graph can be colored with at most k colors,
how big can the largest clique in the graph be?
Go ahead and enter your responses in the text box as provided.